how does someone know what story to
write
i think a lot of times before you write
a story
you have to ask yourself why do i need
to be the person to tell it
and a lot of times you have to say is
there anyone else
better qualified than me you know i
think sometimes
people think i can tell every story i
can tell any story
um maybe i mean but for me it's it's
always
you know what am i qualified to tell
i i prefer to tell stories that you know
have some semblance of truth in my life
or someone i know or something i've seen
just because to me they feel a little
more personal um
i would certainly take a check from hbo
to write for game of thrones but
you know i i can't quite relate to
the fantasy characters and dragons and
whatnot in the same way that i can
relate to
you know more real and naturalistic
things that happen in my
life and that's not to say that you
can't incorporate those things in a
you know fantasy piece or surreal piece
or anything like that
um but just for me i tend to gravitate
towards the
kind of more naturalistic real to life
things whether it's funny stuff
serious stuff you know more experiential
based things i've gone through
what advice do you have for someone who
can't finish writing their story
is that possibly the wrong story for
them or
it just hasn't worked itself out yet
yeah i think
when you write something you're always
going to hit a roadblock somewhere
i'd be kind of surprised if you made it
through smooth sailing without hitting
any
you know kind of roadblock um if you're
struggling though i would
maybe say think about why is it because
you're not connecting
if you're not caring about the
characters you know could it be that
because
if you don't care about your characters
the audience definitely won't care about
your characters and so
you know i've noticed over the years
with writing uh you know like i
mentioned earlier there's a couple
scripts on my computer that sit
unfinished and a lot of that is because
i couldn't figure it out a lot of times
was i lost interest you know
it stopped being fun to write and so for
me
whenever writing isn't enjoyable anymore
i put it i put it on ice i pause it you
know i say i can't do this right now and
you know maybe a year from now i pick it
back up and it's more interesting maybe
i've lived
enough life in that year of time where
i'm able to see the characters with new
eyes
um but a lot of times it could be that
the characters
are too much for the writer you know it
could be that the writer
doesn't have the experience or the
writer
doesn't need to be the person telling
that story maybe there's a
more qualified writer to tell it um i
think it could certainly vary
yeah what about caring about your
character
too much yeah caring about your
too much i think is essential though you
know
like i think if you if you don't care
too much then maybe you don't care at
all like i don't know i've never quite
felt
uh this is only me speaking but i've
never
quite felt like lukewarm or neutral to
any of my characters like
like when i write the main character
itself
i think i want to go to bat for these
characters you know i really want to
fight for them i want them to
to win even if it's a sad story i want
them to find some sort of catharsis
whether
they find it in the film or not you know
a lot of times i'll leave a film vague
and i'll say
you know maybe they do maybe they don't
but i like to at least you know crack
the door a little bit
um so yeah i think caring about your
characters
is super crucial i would say the only
reason
to be cautious of caring too much would
be if you feel that
you know you're showing a bias towards
that character uh at the expense of all
your other characters so for instance if
you care so much about your main
character
that none of the other characters in
your film
get to challenge that main character get
to grow with that main character you
know
i like to think the main character
starts the film
and ends the film a different person um
unless you know maybe there's something
you're going for that they don't do that
but in most films
you want to see some sort of journey for
your character
[Music]
so
you